If I were to go back in time and kind of
give myself some advice on how to advise
founders better, I think that I would be
spending more time trying to help
founders get between stages, get to the
next stage, and less time trying to help
founders optimize the stage that they're
in.
All right, welcome to Dalton Plus
Michael Throwback Edition. On this
episode, we're going to be talking about
the lessons we've learned from the past
five years of making startup videos. And
I got to be honest, when we started, I
didn't think we'd be doing this for 5
years, and it doesn't feel like 5 years
has passed. So, I didn't really have a
vision for how long we'd be making these
videos either, or that that people would
care about them. And I certainly didn't
expect that this is probably what people
know me the best for. Like somehow this
is I guess the most important thing I've
done,
>> which isn't that weird.
>> Not what I expected. And you know, it's
it it's cool because everything I get
when I talk to people are good vibes
where you know the gist is it seems like
we're having fun. It seems like we have
these funny conversations and we enjoy
chatting with each other and I think
people feel like they're a fly on the
wall of like two friends talking about
startups that have a lot of stories and
um people like that. So, so thank you
for for watching these. These videos
have almost been awkwardly rewarding. I
would say it's awkward because the
number of times people will come up to
us and say, "Hey, thank you for doing
this." And it's like it's it's weird.
And you know, so I'll say like, "Hey,
thanks for watching, but like it is
really fun to be able to have an impact
in people's lives and especially
because you know, we're in the startup
ecosystem, you know, we've done some
stuff. I feel like people who are
aspiring to be where we are or even
further than we where we are. It's fun
to kind of give them a little on-ramp to
give them a little like, hey, like you
can be part of this, too." And so, um, I
think that part has been very very
surprising and rewarding. I think that
maybe an interesting question to ask is
what is some of the startup advice that
um we're using ourselves.
>> I mean I think to start with um I think
sometimes the people are are joking
about our videos. They're like, "Oh, you
could just summarize them all by just do
the thing." You know, like like Yeah,
yeah, I get it, guys. Like yet another
video, another Dalton Michael video
that's like don't overthink, don't worry
so much, just do the thing. fair
critique. Okay. Like I can I can I have
no um push back on that, but man, it's
true. Just do the thing. And in my life,
by the way, I I want to pause on that.
And you know, it's kind of like being
like
an an athlete asking you like, "How do I
get faster?" And you say like, "Go to
the gym and train." And the athlete
being like, "But you said that
yesterday." And it's like, it's like,
"Sure, but why? That's still the best
way to do it." And and it's good to hear
it. Again, the point of a coach is a
coach being like, "Hey, you should keep
running." You know, like they're not
actually going to tell you stuff you've
never heard before for the most part,
but their job is to be repetitive and
and to hold you accountable, right? Like
the the role a coach has in your life is
not to say things you've literally never
thought of before, right? Like at least
if you're at an advanced level, maybe if
you've if you don't know how to shot put
or something, the coach needs to tell
you how to shop put. at some point, you
know, there the job of a coach is to be
repetitive in a in a nice way. And so
I've gotten a lot of value of reminding
myself of our own advice. Like I think
about the videos all the time that we've
made and what I would say. And so that's
I've been using that with with, you
know, my business and what I've been
working on is just like, hey, stop
overthinking, dude. Like just go do the
thing. Like that's what you would tell
people, so why aren't you doing it? You
know, that voice is in my head all the
time. It's funny because as I do more
and more kind of research and work in
San Francisco government, you know, I
find myself re reaching for
versions of MVPs all the time. And it's
like really funny because
a common train of thought conversation
will be here's a history of all of the
super big projects that we've tried to
do and failed. It's like okay, good to
know. Great. here's a spec for the next
super big project that we're really
excited to try to do and and you know
and it'll inevitably involve software
because I'm around and and you know I
find myself constantly reaching for that
like you it's the it's the Paul be Paul
Buhight right what's the 9010 right with
10% of the work can we make some
freaking can we can we get something
done here and it's so surprising because
I think that people kind of and I might
have expected myself to try to design
grand solutions. I I'm not convinced
the world is built on grand solutions.
Like I'm not convinced that at any
resolution it's not a bunch of 9010
Legos.
>> Yeah. It's all a hack. Like the more you
know how technology works, it's like a
bunch of hacks on top of hacks. And
that's just that's just how it works,
right? Um
>> well, and that's government. And I think
that's what's so funny is I think that
like in the American culture, government
is kind of simultaneously ridiculed but
presented as this kind of pristine
almost like spiritual thing. And it's
kind of like no, it's a human
organization.
Point to me at a human organization and
show me how it's spiritual and pristine
and like you know what I don't think you
can find one. So I think that's been
really fun has been like one bringing an
MVP culture but then two being able to
deliver the fast wins that MVP culture
can like you know like it's really
motivational to iterate on something
that actually move the bar a little bit.
So I think that's been really really fun
too. other things that come to mind
after five years.
>> I think everyone
knows our advice, but they still want to
hear it anyway.
And I like to think about it um too. And
sometimes they go back to watch the old
videos. It's almost like listening to an
old song. Like somehow somehow even if
you know the answers or you've seen the
video, there's something calming and
meditative about remembering the basics
and focusing on the basics. So again,
this is this is
>> when I come to our own videos or when I
come to our own advice and I think about
our conversations over the years,
>> I'm always just trying to think about
the basics and first principles thinking
and
getting out of my head of, you know,
spinning out and creating super
complicated solutions or super
complicated scenarios, you know. So I
guess
simple thinking is my summary of the of
the thing that stuck with me. I think
for me probably the last thing that
stuck with me is looking back we've
worked at companies at all these
different stages
and at every stage in a startup it's
stressful things feel like essential
um at every stage but fundamentally the
stages are different and I think that
maybe if I were to go back in time and
kind of give myself some advice on how
to advise founders better I think that I
would be spending more time trying to
help founders get between stages, get to
the next stage, and less time trying to
help founders optimize the stage that
they're in. I've met a lot of companies
where I feel as though
engaging in the question of how you
could actually be a big successful
company is is too hard. There's some
maybe some truths that we don't want to
talk about there. So instead, we'll kind
of engage in easier questions like how
do you hit your monthly growth goal or
how do you like add another millionaire
R, right? Like we won't tackle the major
stuff. And I think the other thing that
cames to mind on my front is that like
it turns out to be a great company, you
have to be great at the later stages.
It's like it's funny like I I love
Michael Jordan kind of videos and kind
of stories and so on and so forth. he
was my favorite athlete. And there are
all these stories about one, like how
Michael Jordan could lock in in the
regular season, right? So it wasn't like
he was coasting, but then like two, how
he became an even better player in the
playoffs like like his average got went
up. I almost want to inspire founders to
be on that arc and I almost feel like
sometimes founders imagine a different
arc like the hard stuff is now. like
they they invert that arc like oh the
really hard stuff the NBA final thing is
where I'm starting and every step it's
going to be easier and easier and by the
end it's going to feel like I'm playing
a preseason game and I'm like no no no
no no
and so I think I think if I would go
back in time I would kind of emphasize
that more because I think that the folks
who have the right mindset they're just
more resilient
and like they're they think bigger they
can execute bigger it's almost like
they're flying in like clear air we
always are honest with folks
But let's just talk about the numbers.
The actual number of really big startups
that make it
>> um is small and we're always honest
about that. And to me, our main message
is it's still worth trying if you're
having fun and you're following the
fundamentals and that something awesome
will happen with your life. like
>> yes,
>> like something cool will happen by using
these tools and going on an adventure
and and you know, working with a
co-founder and trying to help people
that
>> kind of like no matter what path it
takes, if you do it the right way, the
the fight is still worth fighting. And I
I stand by that. But my reaction to what
you're saying, which is just the grim
math of of reality here, just like there
aren't 10,000 Michael Jordans out there,
right? there
>> there is not that many um really big
companies and again I just
>> I've always tried to bridge the gap
between tell anyone that watches these
videos there's room for you here we want
you here there's a seat at the table you
you should be a founder if you want to
be you know like basically the opposite
of gatekeeping has always been one of
the messages I've been trying to do and
we have to combine that with being
honest and again maybe we keep using the
sports thing Like I think sports is
awesome for kids growing up and you
learn a lot and I have my kids doing
sports and I know the odds and probably
they're not going to be professional
athletes and those are both true
statements, right?
>> Yeah, I I agree and I and
I think that the piece of advice that I
would give somebody who really really
wants to win is like think about how do
you win in games when so few people win?
Like think about how those types of
games are different from games where
lots of people win. We always talk about
this idea of are you doing the the
average of what the 10 people or 20 or
50 people around you are doing? And like
in some games that's a great winning
strategy and other games that's the
exact wrong strategy.
>> I think that like I wish if I were to go
back in time I would have you know we
get to work with really smart people. I
would have kind of engaged them at an
intellectual level on what kind of
tactics work in games with so few
winners because I think I might have
been able to kind of like addict people
to the like intellectual strategy part
of that as opposed to I fear what
happens too often is addicting people to
the next month's growth goal. It's
almost like chess. I'm not a good chess
player, but basically you can be pretty
good if you just memorize a bunch of
opening moves and beat most people, but
the metag game to be great at chess, I
think, is just totally different. Like,
there's a whole different metag game to
be a really, really, really good chess
player.
>> Yes.
>> Versus someone that,
>> you know, can beat everyone in their
hometown. What I fear is that people are
practicing a game that can make them a
top 10% founder
or give them a top 10% outcome, but like
they're not even practicing the game
that could help produce a top 1% or 0.1%
outcome.
>> And it's like in a power law
distribution of rewards, being in the
top 10%.
>> Not good enough.
>> Well, it's good, but you probably will
always wonder if you could have gone
farther. You know that that's probably
what I would say. But it's still good.
>> Still good. It's still good. All right.
Great chat, Dan.
>> All right. Thanks, Michael.